the rise and fall of mr big welcome to
entertainment tonight everybody you know
we were supposed to see chris knoth on
future episodes of in just like that yep
but in light of the multiple sexual
assault allegations against him it seems
it's lights out on chris's sex in the
city legacy
this is behind the scenes video of sjp
and chris knowth shooting a scene in
paris e.t has learned that it has been
cut from the show's finale
the footage was shot at the same bridge
where big and carey reconnected in the
last episode of sex in the city
[Music]
our source says noth's appearance was
quote cut from the episode and did not
impact the plot the onscreen couple were
also spotted shooting in manhattan in
scenes that have not aired so wait
why was big set to reappear on the hbo
max series after he died of a heart
attack after a peloton ride john
well knoth himself teased the idea of
carrie and a mr big ghost telling vogue
i think there may be something i can't
tell you what but there may be a
haunting that happens we worked out what
would be
exciting in what way to come back
instead of just rehashing old things
kerry was in paris according to one
report to scatter big's ashes where they
would quote reunite in a fantasy
sequence we're told the decision was
made to remove chris from the series
following recent accusations five women
have now come forward accusing knowth of
sexual assault the 67 year old who has
denied the allegations and has not been
charged was spotted out solo in central
park on christmas day our source adds
the decision to remove noth from the
show was agreed upon by the cast writers
and producers
[Music]